days around with us he has defeated jj
alimorandi and he's with christian
carrillo thank you very much alejandro
yes we are with a very happy victor of
today's round that is some conning song
first of all welcome to the show welcome
to st louis this is your first time in
st louis right yeah hello uh yeah this
is my first time and i'm really excited
about being here so
it's it's a great tournament very well
organized so i'm happy to be here this
is also your first victory in this event
how does that feel no actually it was
the second second yeah it was the second
one
and actually it was the same opening so
so i'm extremely happy with this
speaking of the opening let's take a
look at the game right now
where did you feel like you're taking
over did you feel like you got an
advantage out of the opening or where
did you feel like you're taking over the
game actually
i mean it was
my opponent was prepared very well so it
was like
the first line of engine so if you go uh
yeah h4 this interesting line of the sky
yeah it's very very interesting very
um double edged yeah we're a double edge
very difficult to play for both sides
yeah and actually 96 is a great move so
sometimes black may make a mistake on
taking g2 first so
but here
your white is much better okay yeah but
knight b6 is good so be free
yeah
castle yeah and here
very important moment so the first
line of engine is
queenie free and
if black take on g2
white take
with with with the king and it's
extremely double h position but
uh
i felt that my my opponent is
um is ready so i didn't really want to
to go for this crazy lines so i decided
to play more
more safely so i take on b4 yeah queen
e3 and actually i don't remember how
exactly but
let's say f6 i was in game bishop d3 and
i was sure that
my
my preparation was like d5
uh
ed
queen e3
yeah fe cd and there are some like equal
end game but
i liked it for for what because this
pawn on d6 is quite
might be quite unpleasant in some
but it's it's a good line for black
right yeah and i didn't know move fe so
i started to spend a lot of time and
it i might
it looks like you have some bishop takes
a h7 knight g5 all those sorts of tricks
yeah actually there is i spent
most of my time because i didn't really
was able to choose between knight g5 and
bishop h7 because not so clear what is
better
um
yeah finally i decided to go with the
knight
yeah queen h6 decent move yeah here i
was like
not sure about this move but
i was kind of afraid taken with this
bishop because
he just go go away and i didn't really
realize how i
uh
how planets because his next move is d5
and he starts to
um
things are starting to become extremely
complicated right yeah king is a bit
shaky as well yeah and i do i mean
i can
make a long castle but it's also it's
kind of dangerous and all of this
pins they are awesome
i wasn't sure about it i mean maybe
objectively white should be good but i
was a little bit afraid and my opponent
look
looked very confident here so
i decided like to go for for an end game
it was actually it's also double h end
game because
um yeah here
knight g5
and actually i guess d5 is a mistake
but
so he probably is the best move
instead of d5 is rook f8
and i think that this is uh what the
confu the computer
confirms f8 is the right move yeah
because
i'm not sure that i have
something better than than
the knight h7 so
yeah and here d5 for
also d5 looks natural yeah
but
yeah so he said bishop g6 is not the
best move yeah
so i don't worry about the engine too
much yeah
rook recap was played and it seemed like
the game was going through some
complications but this is where it was
fascinating right 96 c takes b3 and you
don't take the rig you actually go h6
which started a whole series of
of weird sequences yeah
yeah
actually maybe
it's much simpler just to take rook on
f8 but i wasn't
instead of which six just take on a fade
but
i wasn't sure about
b2
actually my opponent says that
he would play bishop c4
it could be become
like real double h yes
b takes a two coming b
yeah and actually i i have like five
minutes so
so it's
yeah after age six uh doesn't black have
ideas of rook f1 maybe
he did he better yeah he played rook
four yeah
in the game so
yeah
so h6 yeah rook f1 happened yeah
actually which is a bad move apparently
i'm not sure about rook fan but
yeah he should take on h6 yeah but i was
thinking that it's completely winning
for white because i take on h6
yeah
bishop h7
and then just a b
and i i was like
for that it's like
um looks like a domination because uh
i didn't see really how how play how to
play for black because
everything is hanging and
his king starts to become
you know
bishop b5
try to get rid of that
it looks very scary for black though i
couldn't even castle right is that legal
i guess that's only okay unfortunately
bishop a1 bishop b1 right oh this is
awesome but maybe but i don't have a
threat
but maybe it's better to play just rook
d1 instead
sorry about that um
on b should be five oh i'm sorry not on
this one
h6
and then it takes
on
h6
yeah
it takes
and just castle
here a b a b bishop b5 yeah maybe one d1
but do you have a threat here what if i
just simply go rocket too
okay but then i have checked yeah so
that's a check no wait i can go back to
the take
that's a nice move yeah if it works i
don't know what it does
it doesn't have to go to e7
yeah okay
i didn't see
she didn't see this one it might not be
the end of the world right yeah maybe
maybe that's why
it's not so bad for black to take on h6
i'll just ask the engine and figure it
out actually long castles is the best
move
yeah yeah long castles is winning not
winning as plus one so
we i think we could spend here forever
and we completely such a difficult end
game to us right it's such a difficult
end game
but uh your opponent actually played
this clever resource
h6 rook f1 yeah i was actually happy to
see this move because i thought that i
calculated
pretty good but
maybe maybe it's not so clear so yeah
fun yeah and probably here b2 is
it's definitely
yeah but this is a very strange move he
has to go to d5 right yeah knight g5
looks looks decent and here i guess i
should find kim ji won because if i say
king f2 he takes only two with a rook
and i'm losing right
that's a big difference right
yeah so you have to play king g1 and the
engine still gives you a huge advantage
but it seems like your opponent made
your life a little bit easier with the
movie yeah after b2
no way that responds uh
becoming a queen so
yeah now
my pawn on g7 is just too strong and now
this bishop h7 was a nice finish to the
game
and
well so far kind of a topsy-turvy game
tournament for you sam how would you
rate it
uh could you repeat please it's a it's
been up and down your tournament how
would you rate your own event oh i think
it's could be
would be better because to
[Music]
these two two games that i lost in a row
wasn't uh
one
would
would play for me but um
but yeah
it's it's still it's still a
very interesting tournament and uh it's
not so bad and definitely bouncing back
in you're still only in i am or did you
just finish your gm no i still need to
need one one one gm norm so
i am international master well i could
definitely be here uh the strength of a
grand master we don't doubt that thank
you for joining us here at the studio
and good luck in your remaining games
thank you